In some ways the greatest witnesses.
There are many,
many witnesses of the coming of the civil war.
What causes it?
What's percolating from beneath the society of the South?
We've looked at in the society in the north
and in so many ways,
of course,
the greatest witnesses and their stories have only been with us in a serious,
robust way for the past couple of decades or so,
few decades.
How are those of the slaves themselves
if it was somehow all about them
and in varying kind of ironic ways,
folks on both sides,
we'll say that if it is somehow all about them.
What did they think this week?
You're reading the greatest of the slave narratives.
Frederick Douglass,
his first autobiography published in 1845 is I though it would maintain the
greatest of the slave narratives.
Certainly in the literary sense.
He was an almost mystically brilliant writer for one so young.
He first drafted this when he was 26 he escaped from slavery when he was 20
years old.
You'll find out in the text how he learned his literacy learned first from his
white mistress,
Miss Sophia,
who became like an angelic mother figure to her until she took language away
from him.
The book is full of metaphor.
It is full of one kind of tale and story after another that Douglas Shapes into
telling a free story.
Telling a free story is the great literary critic of this genre.
Bill Andrews,
this put it for a fugitive slave to emerge in the northern states for that
matter,
a future.
This slave who goes to Britain like a lot of Equiano did African barners.
So we still think
and writes his sorry in in Britain,
but for a fugitive slave to write his or her story and publish it in English in
the Western world was just say,
I'm a person of letters.
I am somebody.
I have a history,
I am free,
but I am not free until you let me.
Right?
And I will make myself free if I must by telling you who I am.
I want a fugitive slave could go to England and hold up his book in front of
huge audiences.
Douglas spoke in London at one point before 10,000 people in 1846 and you've got
to hold his little book up in his hand.
He could probably at that moment feel freer than he'd ever felt because he could
actually say,
this is who I am.
I'm not a manufactured identity.
I'm not what you necessarily want me to be.
I won't talk the way you expect me to talk.
I won't scratch my head when I tell my story,
but what a story.
When I was a fledgling graduate student not knowing what I was doing and writing
a dissertation on Frederick Douglass
couple,
few decades ago,
a new book had come out called Young Frederick Douglass.
It was a wonderful study of Douglas as youth.
We had been written by a journalist so he was hard to find.
He wasn't an academic.
This is pre email,
pre Google,
pre lots of things.
I wrote to his publisher,
Johns Hopkins University Press.
I said,
can you give me a phone number for Dick Preston Dixon?
Preston was his name.
They said,
yes.
Here's his phone number.
I was in Washington DC doing research called him.
He lived on the eastern shore of Maryland that much I knew,
which is where Douglas grew up.
I didn't know much about Dick except that he had written this extraordinary book
on Douglas as youth.
In fact,
it was Preston who actually discovered Douglass's birthday.
Douglas was one year younger than he ever knew.
Wouldn't that be cool?
I'll take a year back anytime at this point.
Um,
called him,
he said,
yeah,
come on out to the eastern shore.
Meet me in the eastern community college parking lot at 9:00 AM on whatever
Wednesday morning.
It was in July.
I'll give you a tour of the sites of Douglass's youth.
And it was on of the most extraordinary days of my life.
Uh,
I folded myself and to his station way and we drove back roads all over the
eastern shore.
He took me for a walk through a muddy cornfield is,
I believe it out to the back lot of a field to a bend in Tuckahoe Creek.
And he said,
this is where Douglass was born.
Here's where his grandmother Betsey's Kevin ones and he took me down all kinds
of back roads and we ended up at the Freeland farm.
Read the narrative,
you know the Freeland farms among Douglas three or four masters he had as a
youth Freeland.
He admired the most or respected the most and then he said,
you want to see Covey's farm?
Edward Covey,
the cell called slave breaker.
Douglass had been hired out to or sent to by his master Thomas old when he was a
17 year old,
quite rebellious and rather uncontrollable teenager.
I said,
sure,
show me cubbies,
Fun Ben,
back roads again that I couldn't find it if my life depended on it.
We get out of a car and in my memory we stepped over a fence post and we walked
out this Ridge and Dick said something like,
turn around
and there they were.
He hadn't made it up
in the narrative.
If you've read far enough,
if you read the page 83 in my edition,
you've encountered the most beautiful metaphor and antislavery literature is
Douglas as metaphor of the white sailing ships on the Chesapeake that he would
see from Covey's farm for eight months,
and he would try to dream and imagine his way onto their decks that are gallon
decks as he called them.
And I realized that day sometimes metaphor is not just a metaphor.
Our house stood within a few rods of the Chesapeake Bay.
This is Douglas is Douglas's description,
who's broad bosom was ever white with sales from every quarter of the habitable
globe.
Those beautiful vessels robed in purest white,
so delightful to the eye of Freeman to wish you could write like this when
you're 26
were to me so many shrouded ghost to terrify and torment me with thoughts of my
wretched condition.
I have often in the deep stillness of a summer Sabbath stood all along upon the
lofty banks of that Noble Bay and traced was saddened,
heart and tearful.
I the countless number of sales moving off to the mighty ocean.
Douglas was fond of adjectives.
The site of these always affected me powerfully.
My thoughts would compel utterance and there with no audience,
but the Almighty.
I would pour out my soul's complaint,
a phrase right from the book of job in my rude way,
with an apostrophe to the moving multitudes of ships.
And when you read this,
note what he does.
Then he puts his own teenage voice or his memory in quotation marks
and he speaks to the ships.
You are loosed from your moorings and her free.
I am fast in my chains and I'm a slave.
You move merely before the gentle Gail and I sadly before the bloody whip you
our freedoms,
swift winged angels that fly around the world.
I am confined in bands of iron.
Oh,
that I were free.
that I were on one of your gallon decks and under your protecting wing,
but alas betwixt me and you,
the turbo water's role.
Go on,
go on.
Oh,
that I could also go and he still goes on or another paragraph
milking if you like the sailing ship metaphor for all it's worth.
How many of us,
perhaps all of us,
I think everybody has their Chesapeake.
It may be every morning when you have to go to class.
We all have our own Chesapeake Bay is we've looked out on and wondered,
I wouldn't,
I'd rather be there or how can I get out of here?
Or is there a sailing ship that will liberate me?
Okay.
Telling a free story is what the slave narratives were bound.
They were acts of telling it in some ways made the former slave almost literally
free by an act of language.
Language itself to a former slave who could write was a form of liberation.
We tend to take it for granted today.
These books,
language,
okay.
Abolitionism.
It's roots reformers,
the barriers that they faced.
I'm going to run through this with some speed and then the stages in the
development of an anti slavery in pulse,
let's call it that.
To begin with,
that begins with this idea of colonization.
Colonizing African American freed people or former slaves outside the United
States.
An idea that never lost.
It's kind of beguiling hole and the American imagination even well after the
civil war,
ironically,
and then on to a more radicalized form of antislavery thinking and action
exemplified especially by William Lloyd garrison by,
by a host of other black and white abolitionist,
and I want to work you at least to the story in myth and reality of the
underground railroad since it is so much a part of our imagination of this story
and it would at least I hope,
take us to the point of understanding why that fugitive slave act that we'll
hear about on Thursday and into next week,
that fugitive,
that federal fugitive slave act passed in 1850 and the compromise of 1850 that
flowed out of the Mexican war.
Why that fugitive slave back was so pertinent,
so divisive,
so significant in the kinds of ways Americans were beginning to divide over the
future of free labor and slave labor,
whatever they may have thought about African Americans as their neighbors,
but permit me to use Emerson again at least briefly.
This idea of reform.
I mentioned last time that we sort of hinted there that in American history
we've had at least four major reform eras or waves of reform.
And certainly this is the first in antebellum America from the 1820s through the
1850s.
All kinds of reform ferment came to the surface.
Sometimes that was against flogging in the navy.
Sometimes it was in utopian experiments in communities as sometimes that was in
women's rights.
Uh,
sometimes that was in temperance,
which was by far that is the anti,
um,
alcohol and taboos,
Anti Demon rum movement.
Temperance was by far the most widespread American reform movement and pre civil
war time.
It was probably the only major reform movement that got ahold in the south.
Personal reform of some sort was something that,
uh,
that,
that southern society,
we looked at a slave society,
a very hierarchical society,
certain kinds of personal reform that the dealt with personal piety and behavior
could take hold in this broader social reform that would challenge the social
order.
Not so much,
but listen to Emerson and his essay called man the reformer.
I think about our own times.
What does man born for us at Emerson?
What is a man born for?
But to be a reformer,
and he may be right or wrong about this.
You can decide a remake or of what man has made a renowned Sir of lies,
a restore of truth and good imitating that great nature,
not the metaphor here,
which in Bosoms is all and which sleeps no moment on an old pass,
but every hour repairs herself yielding us,
excuse me,
yielding us every morning,
a new day,
and with every pulsation,
a new life.
Let him renounce everything which is not true to him,
and put all his practices back on their first thoughts and do nothing for which
he has not the whole world for his reason.
Emerson is arguing right or wrong,
that you are a reformer by nature.
Nature recreates itself daily and Soda Humans,
is he right?
Call home tonight to your parents and say,
uh,
you're a senior.
I've decided what I'm going to do.
Dad,
I'm going to be a reformer.
Okay.
If I were your parent,
I'd say of what?
For why everyone's leaving?
Do they pay you for that?
You know,
will it be safe?
Who even talking to
or what?
I'm going to be a reformer.
This was an age though by the 18th 30th
for a small group and the rest assured abolitionist in particular were never a
large group.
They probably were never,
excuse me,
I was in Montana and the weekend giving lectures and the mountains are gorgeous,
but it was cold anyway.
Abolitionists were never even at their peak of organizational action or never
more than probably probably at most 15% of the population of the northern
states.
Now in some communities they might be larger upstate New York,
parts of Massachusetts and Connecticut or New Hampshire,
always a small group,
but like most vociferous and eventually highly organized operating by the
printing press reform groups.
There's significance is much greater than their numbers.
Now what were they up against?
Real quickly,
let me run through these.
I may have begun here last time and it's had to stop
the American abolition.
Is there anybody concerned about slavery?
Let's just take the slavery question has to deal by the 1820s now with the new
generations being born who did not experience the revolution and they are
inheriting now this great experience of there parents,
the American revolution,
but that revolution had at least a two fold legacy.
On the one hand,
it was an event that really ushered those great enlightenment ideas into the
world,
but an antislavery impulse in America is going to draw upon constantly black and
white abolitionists.
They're all going to do it.
Those great enlightenment ideas,
hostility,
the monarchy,
the growth of republicanism,
representative government,
the faith in human reason,
the notion of individual liberty that you're born with certain natural rights.
He's a revolutionary ideas and work them out.
Yeah,
I do there.
How about the right of revolution on a Jefferson's for first principles,
the doctrine of consent,
popular sovereignty,
not a brand new idea.
It's all the way back there in the epistles of Paul and even before that in
certain kinds of writings,
but how many times did the world actually invented governments truly based on
the doctrine of consent
and it's fledgling idea of equality.
Human equality had been put in play,
but the other side of the American revolution is that it had all had also
fostered in the south the necessity of an intensification of slavery's defense.
In many ways,
the success of the American revolution and putting slavery on the run in the
northern states where it was gradually abolished in every northerns immediately
abolish and a few but gradually abolished in most of the northern states by the
1820s the south now had to have answers that had to have justifications at him.
And we went through a lot of those defenses and justifications.
The other day.
This was what Edmund Morgan,
the great colonial revolution historian here at Yale for years,
argued so brilliantly over and over.
It was the American paradox,
this great American contradiction,
largest slave system in the world.
Okay.
Being built by one of its first functioning,
thriving republics.
Three or I'm sorry to
anybody trying to work against slavery.
Even the most gradual modest ways by the 1820s thirties it's got a got a bump
his head right into what we might simply call the sanctity of the u s
constitution.
Constitution was revered in American society.
It was a sacred thing
and look what it was rooted in.
Now garrison is going to call it a covenant with death,
you know,
deal with the devil.
Okay.
Because of its complicities and slavery,
but it's also rooted deeply in federalism and in what northerners and
southerners and northerners would practices,
states rights doctrine,
all that localism that the constitution was designed in Madison's genius to try
to control whole together and you take the three fifths clause and the fugitive
slave clause and the postponing for 20 years of any consideration of the banning
of the foreign slave trade and you realize that the US Constitution is morally
complicit in slavery even though I'd never used the word
why did abolitionism and America or any kind of concern,
let's just put it that way,
about slavery become more radical with time.
It is because ultimately an anti slavery movement in the United States to
succeed had to become extra legal or put another way it had the break the law.
That's why law breaking is such a central theme and Harriet Beecher Stowe is
great novel uncle Tom's cabin.
Okay.
And then of course antislavery activists were up against the increasingly deep
defense of slavery,
which we've already dealt with.
They were up against an increasingly highly organized and widely written racial
theory about black inferiority.
Okay.
And antislavery impulse in the United States was an impulse,
a set of ideas that eventually would have to call cause some form of social
revolution,
legal revolution and political revolution in a society that did not want it.
And in this society,
we're increasingly a tremendous amount of wealth was of course staked in
slavery.
A point we've also made.
Just a last thought on that.
Think today,
just think around you.
Think God of your box for a moment of an issue in the world,
a great concern.
It really affects you or most of us for that matter,
the whole bloody world.
How confident are you in succeeding in solving it
in your lifetime?
World poverty,
global warming,
take your pick.
Uh,
racism
go into
to be an abolitionist and the 1830s was to take on an issue like this and say,
well,
you know,
maybe not in our lifetime,
but
maybe sometime
it doesn't mean they were altruistic.
I'm not sure that we're any altruistic abolitionist.
As you'll see when you read about them in Bruce Levine's book or any other way
we look at them,
they could be as egotistical and his vein and is conflicted in their tactics and
their methods and their personalities as anybody.
Certainly William Lloyd garrison was not an easy guy to get along with.
Now,
the I met,
as I mentioned earlier,
anti slavery in America.
They'll take stages.
It goes through periods,
stages.
The first of these is this idea of colonizing black people elsewhere.
Now,
colonization as an idea is not brand new.
By 1816 on the American colonization society was formed,
but it finally took hold in the political soil of the United States.
In the wake of the war of 1812 was at the American colonization society was
actually founded in the US Capitol.
This thing had congressional funding.
At first,
it was actually founded by some of the greatest statesmen in America at the
time.
Henry Clay was there.
The original meeting,
James Monroe,
John Marshall,
chief justice of the Supreme Court and many others,
especially border state,
upper south leaders like clay from Kentucky,
the great wig who will come,
the kind of father figure of the Whig party,
many of them slave holders like clay.
I owned about 60 slaves and his hemp farms in Kentucky.
The idea here is that somehow over time and that America of the future,
that vast,
infinite,
boundless America of the West,
and eventually this problem of slavery might have to be faced.
But the way it could be faced eventually is if you start gradually removing
black people from the United States and you do it first with volunteer freed
people,
free blacks,
they would be asked,
never coerced was the theory of the original colonization society.
That colonization society of course is the organization had a lot of money in
its first decade or so.
It was such a book geiling idea.
It fits.
It fit in so many ways this generation and was actually the revolution Jen and
revolutionary generation in the immediate post revolutionary generation who
really were infused with what you might call a kind of Jeffersonian idealism or
even a Madisonian ideal.
Is that somehow this America,
yeah,
it had problems or as Jefferson said,
we got to,
you know,
we have got the wolf by the years with slavery,
you can't get off cause the wolf will devour you if you stay on.
You're you to write that down.
We'll forever.
But he said that in private,
but this kind of Jefferson I,
Josue an idealism,
this somehow this grand American continent with its resources physically and
this grand American constitution,
this great experiment would dissolve this problem,
especially if you're helped it.
American colonization society founded the colony of Liberia on the west coast of
the nation of Liberia was founded in 18 2022 by the acs,
the American colonization society.
It would ship approximately 1500 free African Americans to Liberia.
1500 that's it.
Between 1821 and 1831 yep,
and they would found its capital at Monrovia named Virginia is from neuro,
the United States.
President.
Liberia today,
as you may know,
has been through a vicious,
horrifying civil war.
It's a disaster.
It does have the only African woman president.
Now it's,
it's a fascinating story of what's happening to Liberia,
but its roots are back here in the impulse of white Americans to remove black
Americans from their native soil.
Now,
some African Americans bought onto this.
It's the immigration impulse.
Go elsewhere,
make a new start.
Some of them were even inspired by this idea of a return to an ancestral
homeland that they knew so little about.
The colonization had all kinds of flaws at its root.
Well,
you know,
can we can call these flaws when you call these realities,
when you call them whenever we want.
Commonization was essentially rooted in these ideas.
It was the first day or assumptions we might call it.
This is the first assumption was that equality and racial equality in America
was never going to happen.
Just that to start there is what the colonizations would argue be real ain't
going to happen.
Okay.
There was a fear of the rising free black population that that really boomed in
numbers in the wake of the American revolution with all the men you missions
that went on in the upper south and then the emancipation said it occurred in
the north where the slave population of a state like New York had been six or
7%.
It was the fear now of the specter of slave insurrection.
There've been the Gabriel Prosser plot and 1800 in Richmond had been the Denmark
Vesey insurrectionary plot and Charleston and 1822 which brought a lot of
converts to colonization.
Of course,
Nat Turner's bloody and Stovall insurrections in 1831 may colonization and
looked pretty nice too.
A lot of Americans.
There was this idea too that somehow colonization would be a safety valve.
It might only remove five or 10% of American free blacks and slaves over say a
few decades,
but even that five or 10%,
the theory was,
um,
would ameliorate conditions in the south.
It would begin to d fuse this powder keg of our rising slave population being
fueled by the great cotton boom.
And it had a kind of a strange attractiveness,
but mostly to white folks.
It was roundly loathed by make no mistake by a majority of free African
Americans in the north or upper south
and feared to the extent they even grasp
the idea,
my slaves in the deep side,
but it wasn't gradualism that fueled the idea of colonization.
And it was gradualism that a lot of American America's first early youthful
generation of abolitionists thought might still be the best way to go in the
1820s gradual plans had been used.
For example,
in states like Connecticut,
Connecticut passed the law in the late 1790s the said that every slave born in
that state after that date on his or her 21st birthday would be freed.
That's a very gradual plan.
Abraham Lincoln is still voicing this very kind of gradual plan of emancipation
at the outbreak of the civil war.
He's still going,
he's still going to suggest it to the states of Kentucky and Delaware when he
calls them in and ask those states in 1862 to consider emancipation on a gradual
plan and he would even compensate the slaveholders 600 bucks a slaver.
I forget exactly what the figure was.
Yeah.
Gradualism one,
you know,
many people have argued is a kind of the American way,
a longterm plan cushion the chain,
but
several things began to happen,
especially in the 1820 [inaudible] and into the 1830s that radicalized
antislavery thinkers in the United States.
And this is indeed the roots,
if you like,
of a more radical abolitionism the roots of what came to be known among the
Garrisonians as immediate TISM and those roots are these,
let me give you four.
I wrote an essay on the first essay I ever published in graduate schools on this
subject and you never quite forget your argument of your first essay even even
if it wasn't very good,
but what began to radicalize American antislavery activist.
First it was evangelical Christianity.
Some of the radicalism they took from their faith,
they took from the so called second great awakening.
They took from this idea that somehow it was their duty,
it was their place in the world.
Many of them were the sons and daughters of ministers to save souls.
And if you'd been inspired by Charles Gratis and Finny out in Oberlin,
Ohio or as theater,
our weld hat or a number of other ministers across the north,
that it was your duty to go save souls.
It was only one step further.
And Finny told him that to save society as well and if conversion to Christ or
conversion to faith conversion to salvation can happen immediately in a person.
Why not a whole society?
If you can revolutionize a single soul,
why can't you revolutionize a hundred a hundred thousand a million,
a second source
and I can say so much more about the significance of evangelicalism,
this idea of the rebirth of faith,
the rebirth of the soul,
the born again notion.
Okay.
In this year at least we were living in a different kind of era of evangelical
ism in the United States,
although some evangelicals are indeed reformers,
they tend to be seen today largely as political,
social conservatives.
Some of the Evangelical isn't love.
The 1820s in in America and the 1830s became a much more radical kind of
evangelicalism in terms of the social changes that they were advocating.
Having said all of that,
that same evangelical Christian who becomes an abolition is may indeed have been
a very violent temperance advocate and saw a demon.
Rum is as big a demon.
The demon slave holder.
Second cause of this roots of radicalism is what we might call perceptions of
southern intransigence or perceptions of southern truculence.
Any 1820s a lot of these really young,
they're youthful.
They're only in their 20s antislavery advocates are,
some of them are.
Even William Lloyd garrison flirted with colonization at first when he was about
2124 years old.
They were gradual listed first until they began to realize how deeply committed
the south actually was to slavery.
Okay.
And that leaving it to them,
leaving in it,
leaving it to their own resources,
was never going to solve anything.
An early,
early abolitionist sick,
an 1818 George born said quote,
when southerners are challenged on the slavery question,
they quote are choked for they have a negro stuck fast in their throats.
The more and more that early abolition is began to realize just how deeply
committed the south was morally,
biblically,
socially,
philosophically to sustaining the slave society.
Okay.
More,
they began to realize that if they were serious about this,
they had to have much more radical strategies.
The young William Lloyd garrison started by,
by 1829 do you use metaphors in his writings of cement and ice bergs that went
only melt with decades and decades to characterize what he perceived now as this
deep kind of southern intransigent,
a third root of American radical antislavery.
Though it wasn't the British influence.
Make no mistake,
I won't go into any detail here because time doesn't permit,
but these Americans,
these early American abolitionists were deeply influenced by the now decades
old,
two,
three decades old antislavery crusade in England,
which at first then of course the crusade against the slave trades succeeding in
that great act of parliament in 1807,
which was just celebrated last year.
It's still being celebrated in Britain as we speak everywhere.
And then ultimately the movement in England against slavery itself and the
British Empire of course,
will it slaves by active parlor in 1833.
And thirdly,
I would argue that uh,
immediate TISM or a radicalization of antislavery also stems from events.
I think,
you know,
very often historians are asked,
so what was the most pivotal thing or what's the principle cause of,
or what do you expect that you're always asked to predict?
Which is the worst thing you can ask any historian.
Cause the historian will then say,
oh,
historians never predict.
And then they'll go on and do it.
Do you know,
I don't,
no,
if I'm old enough to have any wisdom or conclusions about any of this yet,
but frankly,
sometimes people simply react to events that you cannot predict.
And there weren't events in the teens in 1920s and by the 1830s that did indeed
have a direct impact on this growth of a more radical antislavery Denmark vases
insurrection of boarded insurrection in Charleston 1922 and the 28 or 30 people
who were executed in its wake made huge national news.
The Negro Siemens Act passed in South Carolina in 1822 that said that any ship
that came into Charleston Harbor and South Carolina,
if it had black sailors,
those jails,
those black sailors would be jailed in Charleston while the ship was in harbor.
No white sailors would be jailed.
MMM.
There was a thing called the Ohio resolutions passed an 1824 imagine this,
the legislature of the state of Ohio
pass the resolution suggesting that a gradual plan of emancipation be put in
place over 25 years,
over two generations,
whatever plan they might want to enact.
And they sent this suggestion,
the so called Ohio resolution to all the southern state legislatures
thinking they were going to open a dialogue.
There was no dialogue
and in effect,
Ohio was told where they could put their resolution.
They got letters from a few southern governors that said,
in no uncertain terms,
mind your own bloody business.
This is our society.
This is our system will do with it as we please
that massive growth of the domestic slave trade.
And I already talked about a hundred nearly 150,000 slaves and moving from east
to west and the decade of the 1820s alone and then it's going to double and
triple in the next decades.
No one has to become aware of this
and nat Turner insurrection in the fall of 1831 without a had a radicalizing
effect on people like garrison.
Now who was William Lloyd Garrison?
I want to touch on him and just at least briefly,
well,
I want to get us to this story of the underground railroad.
Although if I save the underground railroad for Thursday,
it still fits because it's right there with the fugitive slave act,
so don't worry if I don't quite get there.
Garrison was by no means the whole abolition movement
by any means.
He did phone and edited and published the longest lasting antislavery newspaper.
I'm all first published in January 1st,
1831 in Boston called the liberator and he would publish it for the next 35
years.
He was cs publishing it in December,
1865 about nine months after the end of the civil war,
he sees publication of deliberate writer on the in the week after.
The ratification of the 13th amendment
is life is complicated,
complex.
He was one complex character,
but he is the real thing.
A professional radical reformer.
He was born in utter poverty in Newburyport,
Massachusetts.
It's father went to see an abandoned him as a child.
His mother tried to raise hand is equally narrative,
well older brother on next to nothing.
At one point she apprenticed him out cause she couldn't feed him and he was
apprenticed out at the age of 12 to a printer and he learned how to make a
printing press work and for the rest of his life.
He said his own print every week he could if he was in town in Boston on the
liberated and he prided himself in being faster.
It's setting print and anybody ever hired.
He did start as a kind of a gradual list.
He went down to Baltimore,
Maryland.
Here I go.
I'm going to talk too much about garrison,
but that's the way it goes.
You went down to Baltimore and he worked with the UN antislavery paper.
They're called the genius of Universal Liberty,
published by a guy named Benjamin,
the Lundy in Baltimore,
a slave state.
There was a young slave growing up there named Frederick Bailey,
but they didn't meet.
Yeah.
Harrison got thrown in jail,
which for him was his a Birmingham jail.
You remember Martin Luther King's letter from a Birmingham jail.
He got thrown in jail for slandering a slave ship captain,
whom he accused of murder
guy sued him.
He was convicted and he about nine months in jail,
which for garrison was pride.
It was also the first time he met and talked at great length with other blacks
who were in jail with him.
The time he got out and came back north and finally got the chance after two
other,
uh,
boarded or failed attempts to credit newspaper,
he finally got his chance and a little bit of money.
You found it,
this paper called the liberator.
A paper.
He would,
uh,
publish without missing an issue and write something for every issue for 35
years.
No.
If you want to understand what I'm Lloyd garrison,
you have to understand them through his ideas and I'll just list them for you
with the briefest explanations.
But it is here where you see now the fruition by the 1830s oven.
The media test abolitionism a radicalizing form of anti slavery,
which by the way,
we'll develop a following in various forms among free blacks in particular in
the north,
but it will also of course began to garner widespread enemies,
widespread enemies.
Garrison and his ilk will come to be seen as very dangerous people,
these reformers,
but if you can remember these six ideas of William Lloyd Garrison owns or do I
have seven,
it's seven.
Sorry.
You can have a handle on what immediate TISM and radical antislavery became in
garrisons hands.
Now,
as soon as,
as soon as you get a leader who goes out and pushes an idea,
right,
it pushes and agenda,
pushes a set of moral principles by which this movement should be run.
Of course,
he's immediately,
we're going to develop an opposition within his own movement and people will
disagree with them,
but number one is first idea was moral perfectionism.
A stern demanding call for abolition is to remove themselves personally from any
corrupting complicity with the American slave system.
Be Perfect even as your heavenly father is perfect.
Said,
garrison,
he was not a trained minister,
but he was a deeply old testament biblical Christian.
His second principle with passivism,
what the 19th century called nonresistance garrison rejected all acts of
violence in any form
well
until the civil war broke out.
More on that later is third principle was anti clericalism or opposition to what
he saw as the hypocrisy and corruption of the American churches.
The Protestant clergy was one of his greatest and make no mistake folks.
Frederick Douglass began his career as an intellectual,
as an auditor and as a writer,
as a Garrisonians.
It was William Lloyd garrison who impart discovered Frederick Douglass by going
down to new Bedford,
Massachusetts and watching this brilliant young 21 year old,
22 year old black guy get up and speak at the African Methodist Episcopal Zion
church in new Bedford and said,
my God,
this kid can speak,
and for the first five,
six years of Douglass,
his public life,
garrison was like his mentor,
a father figure and an intellectual teacher.
Look for these Garrisonians tenants.
When you read the narrative,
it's fourth principle was what he called dis unionism.
No Union with the slave holders was his motto or on his air.
His statement on the masthead of the liberator.
He actually advocated a kind of personal secession from the union.
This was one of those ideas.
He advocated that northern states not participate in the same constitution.
Okay.
More on that later when we get to 1854 and five he took it one step further.
He advocated not voting to vote in an American election.
He believed was to be morally complicit with slavery until the U s constitution
was ripped up and rewritten.
He advocated political non participation with it and how that was supposed to
change the world and save.
It was always a bit of a problem if some of the garrison zone admirers sixth he
was an early and often supporter of women's rights and women's equality which
was another form of radicalism that would make you lots of enemies and the 1830s
forties and 50s
and seventh
he was a tremendous advocate of African American civil rights early
in a time
where they are in effect weren't any.
Now
I'm going to leave you here thinking with me just for a moment.
I think I have two minutes about what's going to happen now.
This antislavery impulse because in part what happened is the two kinds of
abolitionism emerged,
one white and one black
and there were hundreds and hundreds of white abolitionists,
thousands eventually across the north who became deeply involved in organizing
antislavery society is and creating newspapers and running petition campaigns by
the 1830s and eventually even beginning to be involved in the first fledging
antislavery political parties.
Although Gareth and wouldn't go there
if there are also lots of black abolitionists and abolitionist in the north free
blacks.
Many of them though former fugitive slaves who the experience of slavery on
their backs and in their souls and their psyches and often could not risk the
kind of abstractions,
the kind of theoretical debates and arguments over tactics and strategy.
The white abolitionists would spend hours on.
A lot of black abolitionists said,
all right already,
what are we doing for the slaves or what are we doing for my children that don't
have a school?
What are we doing for that child who doesn't have parents?
We need an orphanage.
Okay.
A real division will evolve by the 1840 [inaudible] and into the 1850s between
the very real practical needs of northern free blacks and black abolitionists
and white abolitionists,
but beneath all of this,
the fugitives kept coming.
The fugitive slaves kept coming out of the south.
They never came in.
The numbers that the myth and the legend of the underground railroad teaches us
today,
and I'm going to return to that and myth and legend problem when we begin on
Thursday.
I don't want to leave you with,
this is just a way of thinking your way to Thursday and as you read Douglas,
as you already know,
sometimes I think the poets tell us more than the historians.
I hate to admit it.
Robert Hayden,
the Great African American poet,
wrote mostly in the 1960s
wrote a magnificent poem by runaway slaves who they were,
what they represent,
the story they help us tell.
He called it renegade renegade,
and he rooted it in the refrain of the Great Negro spiritual,
many thousands gone.
Just a couple verses.
We'll return to it on Thursday.
It might be something TA's want to pick up,
runs,
falls,
rises,
stumbles.
I'm on from darkness into darkness and the darkness thicker did with shapes of
terror and the hunters pursuing in the hounds pursuing in the night cold and the
night long and the river to cross in the Jack [inaudible] lanterns,
beckoning,
and blackness ahead.
And when shall I reached that somewhere morning and keep on going and never
turned back and keep on going.
Renegade,
renegade,
run a gate.
Many thousands,
rise and go.
Many thousands crossing over.
Oh,
mythic North,
oh,
star shaped yonder.
Bible city.
Some go weeping in some rejoicing.
Summon coffins in some and carriage is some and silks and some in shackles.
Goals rise and go very well.
See you Thursday.